في تطورات ملف ايران النوويه كذا تقرير
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان الوكاله
تجري نقاشا مع ايران بشان جزيئات يورانيوم
مخصب بنسبه 83
في منشاه منشاه فوردو وهي نسبه قريبه جدا
من درجه نقاء المطلوبه لصنع الاسلحه
النوويه
وحسب التقرير فان ايران ابلغت الوكاله بان
تقلبات غير مقصوده في مستويات التخصيب
ربما حدثت خلال الفتره الانتقاليه وقت بدء
عمليه التخصيب بنسبه 60% في نوفمبر عام
2022 او في اثناء استبدال اسطوانه التغذ
يه قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه نالين
بيربوك انه يجب الا تمتلك ايران قنبله
نوويه وان هذا هو موقف مشترك بين المانيا
واسرائيل ولجهود المشتركه بين بلديهما
واضافت في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظرها الاسرائيلي
ببرلين انهما يشعران بقلق نزاء التصعيد
النووي الايراني ومن تخصيب اليونانيوم
لمستويات قياسيه
النظام الايراني لا يضطهد مواطنه فقط
باكثر الطرق وحشيه بل يهدد الاستقرار
والامن في جميع انحاء الشرق الاوسط من
خلال دعم الجماعات المتشدده كيلانا يشعر
بالقلق اذا التصعيد النووي من جانب ايران
واساءه تقارير الاخيره حول المستوى
المرتفع للغايه لتخصيب اليورانيوم لا يوجد
مبرر مدني معقول لمثل هذا الحافز الكبير
يجب الا تمتلك ايران قنبله نوويه هذا هو
موقفنا المشترك وهذا هو هدف جهودنا
الدبلوماسيه